I'm standing in the middle of New York
City where 7th Avenue meets
conjunctivitis Time Square
once the epicenter of sleazy strung-out
criminals now with his home two sleazy
strung-out criminals wearing Elmo
costumes
many feel they're getting a bad rap in
truth the worst mascots harass tourists
punch cops and push children's but the
best mascots punch tourists push cops
and harass children hello kitty how are
you kitty what you doing with the talk
no you're you're all right you make the
real money around here I know going back
to the hotel rooms of Asian businessmen
right it's Super Mario yes the famous
Super Mario from Donkey Kong is it why
do I get the feeling the only thing
you've ever jumped is a subway turnstile
all right it's a little gamey the
costume okay smells a little bit you
might want to wash that [ __ ] I couldn't
stay in frame after saying that joke
looking like while at 60 minutes will
you please woody I know all your
catchphrases reach for the sky
this town ain't big enough for both of
us I am mentally ill and pose a threat
to tourists this will be sued is full of
diarrhea and cigarette butts by the man
let's stop look at this look at this
outfit you know you're exactly like the
real spider-man except when your senses
are tingling its bedbugs right oh man
it's important to remember this with
great power comes a great fanny pack man
spider-man slightly hungover spider
Superman is here Man of Steel there is
Superman look at you getting a lot of
business today super gnarly yeah it's
pretty good okay how's like asking
Superman what are you more afraid though
kryptonite or running into your old high
school friends in this outfit yes here
with Mickey Mouse what that what's that
Mickey not with his mom what is wrong
why did she go yeah she's Mickey Ricardo
now this is New York so a six-foot mouse
is only the fourth largest rodent on the
table Oh incredible such commitment he's
he's got the costume the mannerisms he's
done everything except learn English
let's sing the theme song if you've ever
heard it
mi see I see a semen stain on your
costume why don't you find a less
humiliating thing to do for another mm
oh you have no idea what I'm singing
here Lady Liberty the five bucks Liberty
has a price remember that and it's five
dollars right Liberty costs less than a
hand shot which Muppet are you Cookie
Monster hello
I think it's percocet monster look at
this I found that man everyone you know
a lot of actors have put their spin on
the character of Batman but you were the
first to bring hepatitis to the role are
you anti-semitic I don't know no okay no
or are you the Elmo they punched the cop
no good so you're just sex offender Elmo
oh my goodness we it's hard to believe
under this costume is Nicolas Cage say
yes to anything look at many getting in
on this look at many getting in under
she's shaking you down in a second see
now you have to give many some many
wants her take see the Mickey's work
together on this side Elmo control that
corner the minion is just amazing I'm
here with Jay Leno
I thought you saved on your tonight your
money I don't get this you're on the
street begging all right J god bless you
to oblivion and beyond there's Lindsay
Lohan alright some mascots have been
talkative and others have been very
evasive so what I'm going to do right
now is to go undercover in an actual
Elmo costume get on the inside and learn
about the machination of these mascots
mm oh you're safe with me you're safe
with these and more breathable it's
working I'm going to jump into them
pictures just something
I am going to bury you now you'll see
myself dish work for me you want me to
help you yeah
I'll turn you out I'll turn you out big
how would you like a picture where you
get to smell
spider-man's ass my ass
you get to smell trying sack okay we'll
do that
[Applause]
see how it's working who's you in Cookie
Monster you in now we got a Cookie
Monster now who's gonna play I want to
see what there put your hand in this way
back while Cookie Monster home to come
by okay
unzipping okay 40 bucks 40 bucks see
that that's how you do it
give them something interesting what's
this now
oh look who wants to be a part of it
Minnie okay this is good
all right we got my whole stable now any
position you want once in a lifetime
photograph what's it gonna be here we go
oh man
[Applause]
[Applause]
you want to snap the cigar five dollars
to smoke the cigar five dollars to smell
this mini cigar genuine mini apps
a lot of guys we learn the law he'll
know
you